sonny pitcher for the cubs is indeed the
professor his name is kyle hendrick some
folks call him
carl jonathan india
swaying in a miss and hendricks cards
him up
now one down a cow will go to work
against jesse winker
the other way that's a fair ball down
the line and it'll kick off the side
wall
winker towards second here's the throw
there and the tag
got him well there's one of the third
basemen in left field
throwing to the other third baseman
who's at second
plays it perfectly off the side wall
winker does not run
well you can kind of see this one coming
it's one of those balls as they hit her
battle runner you're going down the
lines i gotta get two out of this one
but get
tagged on the fingertips they take on
wade
miley chris bryant is aboard so here's
rizzo now
out towards right center that one well
struck and that's good
a towering homer into right center field
chris gets it he ambushes that first
pitch cutter 85 miles an hour
launched for 13. motto stands in against
the right-hander
kyle hendricks vano unloads
hammers that one deep shot to right joey
votto home runs in three straight
reds on the board it's 2-1 he is all
over this pitch
you see that big high leg kick but yet
the body is on time the swing is on time
now nico
horn of the batter swing and a miss by
nico horner and he's down on strikes
that's the first
out of the second inning bali slightly
choking up on the bad
miley goes up to get it helps his own
cause a lead-off single
fastball running across the top of the
zone that's leonard high and miley up on
his tiptoes to line that one into center
field first and second nobody out so now
jesse winker
tapper bobbled and lost
everyone's safe horner could it handle
bases loaded low roller corner on the
move can't get the handle
stitches aquino is struck out swinging
swag and a miss and a big foul tip held
on to
by contreras aquino retired
and now joey votto down it away
gets it to right field
caught miley tag at third throw in from
brian in right cut off
miley scores and joey votto ties the
game
along with getting india to third base
and now to a board with two outs
for a hit ryan around he's in to score
david bodie comes through there's that
cutter moving in on the hands he works
like crazy to
pull the hands in and get a little bit
of this one a little nudge
into shallow left reds down a run in the
fourth
kyle farmer will stand in a hit
kyle farmer clubs one deep left field
wisdom back home run kyle farmer
this one to straight away left field and
the reds and cubs are back to even it's
3-3
might have misread it and then had to
time his jump
and pulled it down nice grab the cubs in
business first and third
and nobody out the 2-1 ground ball to
suarez at third he'll come home with it
the throw on target to barnhart
and he smothers horner at the plate for
the out
well played by the reds suarez
without hesitation just knew what he was
doing with it all along and came home to
get the out
and that loads the bases for joey votto
motto takes and he gets an rbi to give
the
reds the lead a four pitch walk faces
full india home and the reds on top
for the first time today
good pitch and he got him on the 3-2
a strikeout and went away david ross
out of the dugout adam morgan the
southpaw on here
we have no wiggle room comes into a
situation with the bases loaded and one
out
oh two ground ball bouncing up the
middle
underneath the glove of horner covered
on the bag for the force
by bodie winker scores
a 5-3 reds lead and the inning continues
just a couple of outs bases loaded with
one out
in the fifth tony santeon who enters out
of the bullpen
and it will be hayward
[Applause]
up the middle farmer stops on the bag on
the first in time
double play how do you like me now
starting with wilson contreras
swinging a miss 95 blows by
now after missing the slider
on the 01 pitch contreras had to slow up
just ever so slightly on now goes to
work against chris bryant
the pitch swing and a miss struck him
out and that was a fast ball away
back-to-back strikeouts for tony
santiago of
wilson contreras and now chris bryant
matt duffy will stand in
check swing he went dot appeal sanyon
strikes out the side
in a scoreless six runner now at second
base
corner laces that one right center
diving
[Music]
first base umpire scott barry said catch
so they're going to look at it safe
score of the run
it's a one-run ball game pieces loaded
and tucker barnhart will be the hitter
swag and a miss got a big strikeout for
keegan thompson one away
curveball sharply breaking down below
the swing of barnhart
huge strikeout cubs down a run keegan
thompson pitched his way
into a bases loaded no out jam and now
trying to keep this a one-run deficit
thompson kicks deal
reds don't score they had the bases
loaded
with nobody out and they walk away
empty-handed
contreras hitless at four abs
here tonight
[Applause]
out towards left center look out
and we are tied a towering homer
and neither above nor below but squarely
on the back side of that baseball wilson
contreras gives that one a mighty ride
bottom of the night 5-5 yeah this is a
great theater right here
these two guys getting after it and have
this contentious
history garrett ready deals
[Applause]
letting garrett know baez tossed the
back
garrett picked it up the celebration is
on one pitch
one pitch that's all it took